this is Jermaine um this is Jake's
brother who he sees in a dream and he
decides to go visit him because he's
like I haven't seen him in a while and
thing comes along it's technically his
brother too and they go and find out his
life is really stressed out doing all
sorts of very surreal things keeping out
demons stopping this big blue blob from
getting out to take his poster they show
him a little bit of a good time they a
vague now if he's really stressed out he
needs to relax a bit and but that sort
of leads to some tension when they screw
up and some of the demons are getting in
and he finally starts going off the deep
end with all his pent-up rage it starts
really cracking at Jake and saying he
was the favored one and stuff place
catches fire hand fire and they say they
got a stop in he says now let it burn
he's actually kind of happy it's all
gone
and then the blue blob gets out has his
poster they just walk into the forest
chanting up of probably meaning it was
conversation the age-old tale no I
actually I strangely really like this
one and again it kind of like the last
one I can't say it's something where
it's like oh it's clearly blank you know
I can just say there's certain elements
of it that I just kind of pick up and I
see and I really like especially you
like I don't know I've known people that
have had like jobs or responsibilities
they're just the worst and I've known
some people that just like our super
positive super happy about it and just
maybe they cry at night I don't know but
they just stay super super positive
about it and then others that just very
understandably are just super stressed
out and when you see how they live their
lives is like man like you get it and
you don't always know if you can do
anything sometimes you make it better
sometimes you make it worse but it's
like man you just get it when you see
their life you know they have to do
certain things over and over
so yeah it's uh and I don't know seeing
him like watch that place burn but not
only is he happy he's kind of crying
over you know it sort of all going up
and as he it's his way of to kind of let
this all go and maybe start to do I
guess even though it's stuff that
obviously is very valuable because it's
their father stuff but at the same time
he does these weird things like keeping
this monster in this blue cage by this
Teddy Ruxpin doll and he has to keep
switching the tape around in there and
that's this was seem particularly
surreal like there's episodes where it's
like oh well this is just weird and
dreamlike and nothing else it's just a
you know test and surrealism you know
this one it's like hey here's there's
this plot clearly and there's these
ideas and messages we're trying to get
across butts through the strangest
things that they have to do even like in
the opening like Jake opens up the
little cooler there and there's like
people's heads that like they drink out
of and they have to take take the tape
off the mouth to have like steam come
out and get water as anyways and even
when they're going to the brothers place
like there's this little creature that
was like his tail was harpoon and he's
just trying to get out it's like what
was the story with that well let's
remember the harpoon shot out of their
house oh is that what that was okay but
even that poor little thing it's like
what if it was that things just like and
and even those it's just those weird
demons outside I don't know in that even
the head he's like you know throws this
small hand it turns into this big tree
hand why catches fire it is a fire ant
it just seemed so surreal you know and
even that blue blob and if they want the
poster why is it important keeping him
away it's I I really dug it though I
really liked all the like even though it
didn't always make sense you know what
it was kind of trying to get across and
what it was trying to do you know that
getting the poster is like it's like a
big deal but it's also not a big deal
you know you kind of get like he really
wants it and he said dude he just liked
cool I would have given it to you if I
know you have to act like a jerk
whatever and so he served tombs
- we turn into hit this little blue ball
but then he gets out and it's like he's
got the posters I know I don't like just
sort of talk they go into the forest
together and I don't know it was just so
strange but had so many elements that
like I've recognized for real life you
know it's it's very very I don't know I
really liked it I started like these
episodes I can't quite pinpoint or say
why they work or even if they work but
they still like just leave an impact so
yeah that's my thoughts have you well
for one s want to bring up a few things
one germane is voiced by the voice of
Greg universe from Steven universe and
Willie Nelson from the from Steven
universe it's like oh I knew it was
Willie Nelson I'm like are you talking
about it's like how Aqua Teen Hunger
Force okay well it's not that years ago
and Steven universe is newer so I'm not
used to that but uh so there's that -
Final Fantasy 7 plugs Buster Sword yeah
that baby's good appearance which I and
it's the like pretty much the exact
sword or something it's cool
I'm also think it's a slight nod to
Luigi's Mansion when all about thank you
yeah I think it's a slight nod to that
as well now for me like watching this it
shows just how much kind of an asshole
their father was I mean it was already
kind of shown before he wasn't the
nicest guy but think about he did you
like give me my cut back I want my cut
back let's all do the other ones like
can I have my poster
I want my poster that's all I wanted
they wanted their stuff back dear father
what are you doing kit went from the
tecar camera there is there's a joy
there to cover your shame um but I mean
like he just kind of seemed to go around
taking stuff from demons and then when
the demons got pissed off it was their
fault not his
and like it's kind of douchey yeah I'm
he stole his demons poster and he wants
it back and he's like Nike and
tough it's like wow that's all
think about it if Germaine gave back
that one demon his debt tapes the demon
would leave well I think there's
something to yeah it's kind of like
taking on the responsibilities of the
Father actually I didn't even want but
you know it's like upholding that so
when the place is going up in smoke it's
like well it's just kind of what he
didn't want anyway now he has this out
you know see for me I saw the episode as
a sins of the father as in the sense of
should the sins of the father affect the
son all these things that their father
did wrong and horrible and all that
stuff is now on Germaine every day he
has to live with everything that their
father did wrong
including running down there at least
twice a day to flip that tape and it's
like should he have to do that because
that's what his father did he's saying
they're valuable he's saying their use
you know they're worth something but in
the end are they really you know and
it's like once let's say I did something
horribly wrong should it affect Bri and
should we have to live with what I did
well I even go to like I mean we're kind
of I'm sure every generation faces us
but I mean like what we're talking about
now it's like you know hey like whatever
the either our generation of the
generation before us like kind of
screwed the next generation as all other
reasons like there's not that many jobs
and white college costs even more and
it's like you can't ever really pay off
the loads instead it's like we have not
left this where it used to be
whatever yeah graduate high school you
know or college you go get a job it's
like yeah how that's not so easy and you
know top of it you paying an arm and a
leg that you may never ever get back
yeah so it's one thing I'm here that
more and more now just how it's like one
generation has completely screwed the
other I'm not sure if it's our
generation or the one after us or
whatever but oh one of us don't feel
good I'll say this I don't want to blame
us if anything I'll blame the one before
us but we weren't all that great either
I was gonna say I think we well my
generation is called Raynaud's
generation
it's every generation builds upon build
up and breaks down the previous
generation yeah and they're yeah that
every every generations got their pros
and cons and stuff like that you know
there's the quote-unquote good old days
always have a lot of a lot of
really terrible babies and the good
old days we used to beat our wives
yeah we had racism to go around for
everybody but no for me I saw it as you
know Jermaine has been forced by dealing
with what his father did wrong or right
in his eyes and is forced to do this day
in and day out no matter what if he just
handed back everything that was stolen
you wouldn't have to do it hmm
but because he believed in his father
and he loved his father and he felt that
this was important he start doing it and
it stresses him out and it does you saw
he flips out in the end going oh my god
I want a normal life you know well
something about that family connection
to where there is a sense of light
because you see people where it's like
someone the family may start to you know
something happens to their body or even
their mind or something and somebody has
to go take care of them and you know
it's stressful you know it's so hard and
you know there's times where they just
like you saw they're like just crack who
either when they're alone or when
they're with somebody else
but you know it's still family and for
all we know maybe the person didn't
treat them well or doesn't treat them
well or vice versa may they're great but
uh but you know it's like they're still
always that connection so it does always
make it tricky when it's like even if
somebody's doing something really wrong
or really bad it's like it's still your
blood it's still your family it's still
you know who you grew up with and it's
even if you know what's wrong it's still
hard to make that separation I disagree
completely really if your parent brother
sister or whatever treated you like scum
for your entire life and then all son
they're on their deathbed you're
supposed to just like oh it's okay not
supposed to I didn't say it's supposed
to
I'm saying that it's still it's still
tough even if like I don't see not for
me like your scumbag tough
I mean it's there's still a sense where
it's like you know it's May because you
know we are raised so much of what even
with different families and stuff like
that like what a family should be you
know I'm the support and the care and
stuff like that where if you know you
get that or you don't get that it's one
of those things where it's like it's
still your family whether it's like you
know this whether it's like a mental
connection or physical connection or
whatever there's always going to be a
connection there no matter how far you
try to chop it off I'm trying it's kind
of like what you know what was that
you're always you know it's like
whatever religion you're raised with
even if you go to another or block it
all out or whatever there's always gonna
be that seed in there somewhere I never
truly like oh yeah yeah anything like
cuz it's like the first thing you're
introduced to and like no matter what
there's always gonna be in that
connection so I think even if somebody
like does cut off and be like no I know
this is wrong I'm not doing it it's that
connection is still always gonna be
there's never quite gonna leave even if
it's like you know it's not logical you
know it's like hey I know this person's
doing wrong I'm not gonna follow that
I'm gonna do the smart thing yeah you
know that connection no matter what even
that small is always gonna be a
connection no matter what it could also
be along the lines of so let's say I
don't know
I started a video game company and I'm
doing really really well and I'm dying
and I leave it to Bree should Bree take
on my job and my responsibilities and
run said company or should she do what
she wants should she follow in my
footsteps because well you know I gave
it to her and I started this and it's
Mike um you know following the footsteps
of your parents or do what the hell you
want to do one then even then that did
kind of like with this - it follows with
these other responsibilities of the
people that person has impact yeah so
like you know she could go is such a
weird example but she could go and just
like you know do whatever she wants I
don't want to do this I'm gonna you know
get rid of the company and do my own
thing or take it a totally different
direction that
you know maybe a kebab but whatever is
what I really want to do and always want
to do and like you're putting these
people's jobs at stake Evan you know
doesn't work you know they're totally
gone but if you go the other route it'd
be like no I want to do what my father
did and continue the legacy and stuff
and maybe that's not what you want to do
and you could totally destroy your
dreams and your life you know dedicated
to this um and then you're not even sure
if you're good or not you could totally
bond that too so I mean I think back to
we'll say the good old days before us
where parents or you know people started
their own companies built it up from the
ground up and everything and kept like
passing it down to their kids
even though said kids maybe didn't want
to do it but they felt almost out of
obligation that I have to keep said
store running because this was my
father's dream and instead and how much
resentment can you build up working in a
job you may not want to work in just
because it was someone else's dream and
not your own when do you four go and
ignore someone else's dream to go after
your own yeah you know and I say follow
your own dream that's everyone else go
for it make it happen
no I think and I think that's kind of
that's kind of the message of this one
or at least more why it's leaning
towards cuz I mean you see the place
burned up not always he happy but he's
crying over it you know he's kind of you
know just this flux of emotion about the
hand as he reaches to the shelf the hand
hands on the shoe because then you see
it's a hand on the Shelf but it's like
for a second you just don't we'd ended
on a fun note yeah I guess we did get
pretty deep in this so yeah
nothing else to say but there's a cat on
the tripod yeah you better on cat